what about turning the Republican Party
more libertarian and you know this is
something that my colleague Matt Welch
and my colleague Katherine mango Ward
people have reason have we've written a
lot about and it seemed even a few years
ago on the the the Tea Party wave and
what not people who were coming into the
Republican Party were about limiting
spending balancing the budget getting
out of a lot of social issues as a focus
of national government can anything be
done to make the Republican Party more
libertarian yeah I again I think so but
I can imagine imagine such a situation
that word it seep into like a Rick and
Morty multi where it's like an
alternative universe
I can imagine such a situation but it's
hard to sort of perceive like it just
like it was hard to perceive the whole
Trump thing like that it was going to
change the way the Republican Party
views itself and changed a lot of a lot
of people's positions I I don't know I
think it's possible but again if you
could change the Speaker of the House
and have a libertarian Speaker of the
House and independent minded Speaker of
the House you'd have a bigger chance of
shifting the party so is Paul Ryan like
a bully I mean he say you tried to get
me in as much trouble as possible
absolutely it's like it's like seventh
grade all over again
talking about arbitrary Authority I did
he dunk on you or something it's like he
has never dunked on me but you were you
were also very much and I mean this was
a real testament I think to your to your
character and your principles John
Bainer really disliked you yeah yeah so
a this is you know but so
but in in many respects Boehner was the
better speaker and this is I mean it's
hard to say like my first gentler he
looked I heard Walter Jones said he
might write an apology letter to me for
try now stir but like the thing about
Boehner was he didn't like you but he
was open about it like he and and I
appreciated that I could appreciate that
I didn't think you did a good job as
Speaker but I at least respected that
like if I wanted an amendment even an
example that actually happened without
telling you the specific words Boehner
used because they're they're not not
safe for work so I wanted an amendment
on a bill and and he was getting a lot
of pressure to put this amendment on the
floor so he he called me into the back
of the House chamber to meet with him so
we're just sitting there like in the
House chamber and it's mostly empty and
there's just two of us in the back row
and he pulls out my he pulls out a sheet
of paper I'm like what's he got on this
piece of paper like what's it what's he
going to read to me and and it's like a
whole bunch of I see a whole bunch of
like small paragraphs and I'm like what
is this thing and he goes I see you've
been posted a lot on Facebook and
Twitter and he just starts ripping into
me swearing calling me the worst names
he can think of and I won't tell you
what he said because it was pretty
extreme but I even said to him Mr
Speaker I don't think you mean that
about some of the things he said I like
liked it because it was really harsh and
then and then he repeated it again with
with a few extra colorful adjectives so
so so he was pretty firm on his view of
me but then he said I'm gonna give you
your damn Amendment and so he let me
have the amendment vote and I could
respect that I walked away thinking well
that wasn't so bad like now now with
with Paul Ryan there is no chance of
that he's not going to swear at me he's
not even going to consider me he's not
going to think about me like I'm not
like there's no there's no sense in
which he'll even acknowledge that I
exist so it is a totally different
dynamic and it's worse in most respects
because I would rather have the guy
swearing at me and letting me have a
vote then not not considering me at all
and under this current speakership we've
had the fewest open amendments of any
speakership we've had zero we've had
zero open rules so we haven't been able
to offer amendments on bills on the
House floor we can't go to the House
floor and offer our amendment on the
floor everything has to be pre-approved
by the speaker every single amendment
pre-approved and under Boehner you had
many opportunities where you'd go to the
floor and you could just walk up and
leadership could not stop you because it
was an open process and you could offer
an amendment and as long as it was
germane to the bill you got to vote on
it and this was true on basically all
appropriations bills now we don't even
do appropriations really they just come
up with some omnibus bill they spring it
on us in the last second and they say
this is the bill or they do a CR and we
just send you a video resolution so we
don't have these opportunities anymore
to debate amendments that we want to
offer that aren't pre-approved by the
leadership team
you
[Music]